هذه المنازل في جنوب اوكرانيا بالقرب من
زبرجيا تقول كيف ان روسيا دمرتها من خلال
ضرباتها الاخيره
ضربات تعد الاحدث في سلسله الهجمات التي
تستهدف البنيه التحتيه الحيويه الاوكرانيه
منذ اسابيع التي ادت الى انقطاع الكهرباء
والتدفئه والمياه في انحاء متعدده من
اوكرانيا
حسنا انتم تحاربون لكن قاتل الجنود لماذا
يموت اطفالنا ابني في حاله حرجه جاء فقط
لزياره جدته
رئيسكي قال ان اربعه على الاقل قتلوا في
هذه الهجمات مضيفا ان نحو 70 صاروخا تم
اسقاطها
كله
هزيمه الارهاب لكن للاسف مازلنا لا نستطيع
ضمان سلامه كامل
ضربت الروسيه
اوكرانيه هاجمت قاعدتين في جنوب روسيا ما
ادى لمقتل ثلاثه جنود واصابه اربعه اخرين
والحاق اضرار بطائرتين
محاولات
في منطقه الرياض
قوه كيف تبدي قدره متزايده على ضرب اهداف
روسيه استراتيجيه ابعد بكثير من خط
المواجهه في جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا